[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends welcome to
amazing facts would you like to hear an
amazing fact on June 4th 1923 jockey
Frank Hayes who had never won a race
before took off through the gates of
Belmont Park on Long Island the horse he
was riding that day was a twenty to one
longshot called sweet kiss incredibly he
and the outsider horse made it to the
finish line first but all was not well
evidently in the middle of the race
Frank Hayes had a heart attack and died
but somehow he stayed in the saddle his
death was not even discovered until the
race officials came to congratulate him
and his lifeless body dropped out of the
saddle in spite of this Frank and sweet
kiss were declared the winners some
speculated the fatal heart attack might
have been brought on by Hays extreme
efforts to lose 12 pounds to qualify for
the race others thought the shock was
that he was actually winning and it
brought on a heart attack the horse
sweet kiss was renig named sweet kiss of
death and no jockey ever rode her in a
race again friends you know the Bible
says that the Christian life is a race
you can only win by dying first stay
with us we're gonna learn more on this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 phone call 800
God says that's eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven one more time
call an 800 four six three seven two
nine seven that'll bring your Bible
question or questions about living the
Christian life into our Studios here in
Sacramento California want to welcome
our friends who may be watching on
Facebook right now we've been streaming
on a very hi-tech telephone the last few
weeks and we've just expanded our
audience quite a bit so you want to see
the Facebook post you can simply go to
Doug bachelors Facebook page and we'll
be streaming that there and pastor Ross
how you doing doing well pastor Doug and
let's start with a program with prayer
dear father in heaven we thank you once
again that we have this opportunity to
study a word and when I ask your special
blessing as we search the Scriptures be
with those listening Lord we pray for
your leading in Jesus name Amen amen
ambassador you open the program with a
very interesting fact we were talking
about it before the program here is a
horse that won but in the process it's
right had died this is kind of a strange
thing that they never rode the horse
again apparently it was a good horse it
won the race but they must have been
enough you know I don't know where there
was whatever was but they never rode it
again it never won a race at least not
with a rider on it people involved in
horse races believe a lot in luck
right and they probably thought this is
an unlucky horse and no jockey I wanted
to get back on sweet kiss who has
renamed sweet kiss of death
but it's the only time and this is in
the guinness book of world records that
a writer won a horse race while dead and
what's even more incredible i didn't
mention this was not the typical track
race this was a steeple race so the
horse was jumping over ditches and
hedges and fences and somehow he was
just clinging to the the reins when he
died and had a heart attack we know they
don't know but he somehow finished the
race dead and one of all things the
first time he ever won that's so sad
but you know I couldn't help but think
of a paradox in the Bible that is
similar in that the Christian life is a
battle you only win through surrender
and the only way you can really live as
a Christian life is by dying first Jesus
tells us that whoever comes after me let
him deny himself take up his cross and
follow me so I grew up being crucified
with Christ
like in Galatians 2:20 Paul said I die
daily we're born again every day but we
need to die to self and Paul talks about
that race he wrote in second Timothy
four four six and seven just before he
was executed by Nero he said I am
already being poured out as a drink
offering and the time of my departure is
at hand I fought a good fight I have
finished the race and I've kept the
faith again Paul was someone who said I
die daily and he finished the race and
he says I've won
there's laid up for me a crown which the
righteous judge will give me Jesus said
in Luke 924 whoever desires to save his
life will lose it but whoever loses his
life from my sake and the gospel will
save it friends if you want to be a
winner and if you want to really live
then you need to understand what it
means to surrender yourself and we have
a very important book if you've not read
this before you should get it read it
and share it we're gonna make available
for free tonight the book is entitled
the surrender of self and that is a free
gift to anyone who will give us a call
and just ask for it again the book is
called the surrender of self and the
number to call is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven that is
a resource phone line as for the book
the surrender of self
we'll be happy to send it to anybody in
North America again the number is 883
five six seven four seven and if you
have a Bible question our phone line
here to the studio is 800 four six three
seven two nine seven that's 800 four 63
72 97 that'll bring you right here into
the studio with the old Bible question
well pastor doc I think we ready to go
to the phone lines our first caller that
we have is Michael listening in
Washington Michael welcome to the
program hi welcome to Deeping brother
Doug and brother Jean how are you great
thank you for calling and your question
is when Jesus comes with his kingdom to
earth what happens to heaven well when
we think of heaven there's three words
that are translated heaven in the Bible
one word translated heaven is talking
about the atmosphere around the earth
the Bible will talk about the birds in
heaven and the clouds in heaven and
another way the word heaven is used it
talks about if the Sun Moon stars in
space the third heaven Paul says I was
caught up to the third heaven he is
talking about the dwelling place of God
and so that heaven doesn't cease to be
heaven jesus said I've gone to prepare a
place for you I will come receive you
unto myself this is John 14 that where I
am you might be also so he's coming to
the dead in Christ will rise the living
are transformed given glorified bodies
and he brings us back to heaven into the
mansion he's prepared so I'm not sure
what do you mean what will happen to
heaven do you think because it's vacated
for a few minutes those are gonna be
like a an empty space or an empty void
or something you know there's an
interesting verse in Revelation pastor
Ross probably remembers where it says
there's silence in heaven for about the
space of half an hour and you know
angels in heaven are always praising God
you read in Isaiah they're saying holy
holy holy so the reason that it would be
silent in heaven is because Christ has
come to the earth - with it says he's
coming with all the angels that would
make heaven silent yeah
Revelation chapter 8 first one learn
yeah so you know it's definitely it's
real Christ is coming and heaven will
not
you know stop being heaven but all of
heavens going to be involved in a
victorious parade bringing the redeemed
back into the City of God you can also
read more about that in Revelation 21
when it talks about the New Jerusalem we
have a free offer we'll make available
to you Mike and anyone who wants about
him and it's called heaven is it for
real the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can ask for the study
guide called heaven is it for real the
answer is yes heaven is very real but
get the study guide and learn all about
a number of Bible verses in there I
think anyone who gets it will enjoy it
the number Yanni's eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven a next
caller that we have is Ron listening in
Canada Ron welcome to the program
hi there pastor Doug and Pastor John me
Ron thanks for telling me you're welcome
I was wondering I believe in the Godhead
God the Father God the Son and God the
Holy Spirit
but the santi Trinitarian doctrine seems
to be so prevalent nowadays and in in
our church and I was wondering about a
couple verses that they throw at us
one was first Corinthians 8:6 and and
another passage was mark 12:29 232 I was
wondering if you could help explain
those for me yeah let's start with 1st
Corinthians 8 verse 6 and it says yet
for us there is one God the Father of
whom are all things and we for him one
Lord Jesus Christ through him all things
and through him we live well first of
all when it says one God that shouldn't
trouble us because you know Moses I
think Paul here is just quoting the
great Shema where Moses says hear o
Israel the Lord our God is one the word
one biblically is not talking about
numerical quantity and it's talking
about a unity now when it says one God
and Father sometimes the Bible seems to
interchange that Jesus is our Creator
and Jesus is our Father in the sense
that you look in Isaiah it said for unto
us a child is born and unto us a son is
given and his name shall be called
wonderful counselor
mighty God the everlasting father the
Prince of Peace
yea if all things were made by Christ
and in that sense he's our Creator so I
want to you know I want to think that
the Godhead falls on this verse well you
know it's interesting the verse you
referring to the in 1st Corinthians is
referenced or it's quote from Malachi
chapter 2 verse 10 where it says we have
we not all one father has not one God
created us well you realize when you
study the creation account in Genesis it
says in God said let us make man in our
image none of us in Jonna talks about
the word all things were made by him
without him was not anything made that
was made so without a doubt the Father
Son and the Holy Spirit they're all part
of the deity they part of God they are
God each of them have the
characteristics of divinity now you had
a second verse and Mark I think you said
yeah mark 12:29 232 I was also wondering
if 1st Corinthians 8:6 if the
punctuation is not necessarily inspired
if I could have something to do with
misunderstanding that verse well that's
a good point that often happens with the
the Greek is those sentences can be
carved up the wrong way with commas and
periods that were not in the original
and alright let's go to mark he's in
mark chapter 29 or 12 verse 29 29 to 32
oh yeah and here of course Jesus is the
first of all the commandments is hear o
Israel the Lord our God is one love the
Lord with all your heart the Lord God
with all your heart your soul your mind
and with all your strength this is the
first and Great Commandment so I don't
know why that would be any different
than what we just talked about where
yeah well you know there is one
interesting feature just to add to that
in the original Hebrew there are
different senses of one's in plural form
the others in singular form for for the
word translated one in other words you
have a plural form of one meaning when
it talks a husband and his wife shall
become one that's right the God of the
Father Son and Holy Spirit it's uses
specifically Deuteronomy chapter 6 verse
4 it says the Lord thy God is one it's
in the plural form so it's giving you
idea that it's talking about one in
purpose not necessarily one in numerical
value
yeah and also when Jesus prays in John
17 he's praised that the Apostles are
twelve of them might be one he suggests
as the father and I are one so that I
think is a very telling passage and John
does more to explain the deity of Christ
and probably any of the Gospel writers
hey you know I really appreciate your
question and you may have seen the book
we have a book called the Trinity is it
biblical we'll send you a free copy if
you would like that and you can just go
to our website if you'd like and look at
it right now there or and that's amazing
facts dot or RG or you can order it on
the phone yes just call the number eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can answer the book called the
Trinity is it biblical my next color
that we have is Sebastian listening farm
looks like Palm Beach Sebastian welcome
to the program Astrid Ogden pastor Ross
good evening guys thanks for taking my
call thanks for calling yeah so my
question tonight is on vegetarianism so
I know that the original diet of Eden is
you know was a vegetarian diet and while
I know it's not a sin to eat meat I've
recently been trying to adopt more of a
vegetarian diet however I've been having
some difficulty in maintaining it so I
also go to the gym regularly about four
times a week and I was finding hard to
use my post exercise workouts on a
vegetarian diet so is there any tips or
resources or books that you could direct
me to that have some nutritional and
tasty vegetarian recipes thank you
alright he appreciate your question on
that now first of all we are not saying
the Bible says you have to be a
vegetarian but it is true that the
vegetarian diet was the original diet
for Adam and it will of course be the
diet in heaven you will not have a
chick-fil-a or Burger King in heaven
there's nothing will die the animals
will not even eat each other in heaven
so you're on the right track there you
know one thing I'd mentioned I heard you
talk about you know in your workout you
do some aggressive workouts and that's
good I can't count how many Olympic
athletes and triathlon athlete
and runners are vegetarian not just
vegetarian many are vegan and they have
found incredible endurance and strength
you know if you eat a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich you get lots of protein
you get fruits you can depend on your
jelly I mean so it's not hard to get all
that you need I've been a vegetarian for
Oh what thirty five years now
pastor Ross and I played racquetball
today I'm pretty fast for an old yeah so
yeah yeah you can you can get plenty of
protein you know eaten well they say if
you eat a lot of beans there's a lot of
protein in beans different types of
grains
there's protein they're actually they
say that the the the way to absorb the
protein is even better if you're going
with more plant-based type of proteins
think of a book well yeah there's a book
called go ahead I was just gonna mention
we do have a study guide I don't think
you get specific into eglise keys the
biblical principles called God's free
health plan oh yeah in the kitchen we
have a book you can read it for free
till a death in the kitchen and it talks
about some of the the benefits of that
and you can get both on our website yes
you can see if we're on the website or
you can just call and ask the numbers
883 five six seven four seven and you
can ask for the study guide called God's
free health plan and the book with an
intriguing title death in the kitchen
will be able to send that anybody who
calls and asks alright that should be
good we thank you for your question next
caller that we have is NAT from
Charlotte North Carolina that's you
there hey guys love your ministry I
don't drink I agree with you it's for
witness and besides my daughter who's on
medication she can never drink so I have
to take the example for us
good for you thank you
that being said I'm wondering how you
reconcile the idea that new wine is just
grape juice with Acts chapter 2 verses
12 to 13 all right let me read this for
our friends that might be wondering what
that says we try to be mindful a lot
our listeners are in their vehicles and
they can't always run to their Bible
when they were filled with the Holy
Spirit and they all begin to speak other
languages some of those listening are
mocking and they said they are full of
new wine but Peter stands up and he
raises and with the eleven he raised his
voice and men of Judah let being known
to you this day we're not drunk as you
suppose in verse 15
x2 since it's only the third hour of the
day now the very fact they said they are
full of new wine is because that was a
sarcastic answer these are mocking it
says they're mocking sometimes people
would be stumbling down the street in
Jerusalem and someone say oh you've been
drinking this oh no no it was new wine
and so they used to mock people say oh
yeah you're full of new wine and they
they met it really as a mock clearly new
wine is not fermented that's why Jesus
said you do not put new wine and wine
skins where you've had fermented wine
because the fermented wine yeast then
will activate and begin to forget
ferment the new wine which is fresh
grape juice and it expands and bursts
the skins so the new wine is very
clearly unfermented there's no other way
to describe on fermented wine in the
bible but new wine think the key to that
verse is they're mocking and they're
saying new wine sarcastically you still
there yeah so you're basically saying if
someone's speaking from today and so I'm
saying ah well you're full of grape
juice
and in a mocking way you're you're
saying well you know they create great
piece is just synonymous with wine and
the sort of mocking yeah well no one
would use that expression today this was
this was an expression of those times
there were only a few things you could
drink and people who were often tipsy
they would say oh it wasn't fermented it
was new wine and so they used to mock
others by saying yeah you're full of new
wine but they met it sarcastically we
don't use that expression today so when
a person speaking in tongues we would
never use the new wine expression that
was analogous to them
so hopefully that makes sense you know
and then another example is Christ at
the Last Supper he said he gave them
unfermented grape juice and he gave them
unleavened bread and he said I will not
drink of the fruit of the vine again
until I drink it with you new in my
father's Kingdom
so even Christ you know in heaven we're
not gonna be drinking alcohol and you
know anyway so yeah I have a book on
this that I think will answer a number
of questions and it's called the
Christian and alcohol I think I cover
most of these points in that book to
receive that just give us a call on the
resource phone line the number again is
883 five six seven four seven you can
ask to the book called alcohol and the
Christian will be able to send it to
anybody who calls and asks you can also
read it for free online those who are
outside of North America just go to the
amazing facts website mazing fact 0rg
and you'll be able to read the book
there as well
our next caller is Ronald listening from
California Lancaster California Ronald
welcome to the program
dude being a pastor thank you for taking
my call thank you um I'm gonna piggyback
on an earlier caller I'm gonna have a
veggie tale for you okay I have we have
a little in-house family debates not a
family feud my in-laws my wife's family
they are vegetarians due to religious
reasons and they were meat eaters were
carnivores and I'm a hoping it's Elvis
biblically they're giving me scriptures
in the Book of Daniel that starts with
chapter 1 verse 12 through 16 about how
he wouldn't take the Kings delicacies so
they had vegetables and and they changed
a countenance and they're telling me
that that's biblical evidence that the
vegetarian diet is biblical and it's
actually spiritual and if you if you eat
meat versus being a vegetarian
you'll you'll have a like an older
looking countenance and you won't be
able to be as spiritual as those that
eat vegetable that's kind of that's what
we're getting from them and so when I
read the Bible maybe I'm wrong but I
don't see anywhere where Jesus was a
vegetarian
all right good points first of all
Daniel 1 it does say
that when Daniel and his friends were
given ten days of testing and they asked
for a vegetarian diet and of course part
of the reason they asked for that is not
because Daniel was a vegetarian but when
they were told they needed to eat from
the Babylonian kitchen that probably
also included not only animals
sacrificed to idols which they were
uncomfortable with but unclean animals
that they were just forbidden to eat
that it was called an abomination so to
play it safe he said just give us a
vegetarian diet and he didn't want the
King's wine either for you know obvious
reasons so at the end of that time they
were brighter when tested they did have
you know elasticity in their step they
looked better and that chapter ends by
saying Daniel lived not only did he
outlive Nebuchadnezzar and outlive
Nebuchadnezzar her son and outlive
Darius he lived until I don't know the
beginning of King Cyrus I'm pretty sure
it says so that that is a good point
there I don't think that's the only
point I think some of the best arguments
are not just in the Bible in Genesis
where you know that's the original diet
and in heaven where we're going to eat
from the tree of life and all the
animals are vegetarians but I think
there's plenty of scientific evidence
that is in pastor Austin I went to a
men's meeting today Christian men's
meeting the doctor was talking to us and
the doctor said the jury is in if you
want to reduce your chances of prostate
cancer eat a vegetarian diet and you
know you just see in all of the evidence
and the studies today if a person eats a
balanced vegetarian diet they are gonna
be a lot less susceptible to a number of
diseases so there's benefits correct
Jesus was not a vegetarian and as I
mentioned earlier there's no Bible
command that you must be a vegetarian
there is a Bible command if you're going
to eat meat do not eat the abominable
meats that are described in the Bible
and you'll be better off so that's a
long answer I'm sorry go ahead yeah I
agree i but it has nothing but again and
we could agree on this and that's that's
the whole debate is it has nothing to do
with my with our eternal destiny or what
we're going to live in eternity and in
like I said geez
as Christ our risen Savior in a
resurrected body said he was hungry he
didn't ask for a tofu burger or some
broccoli he asked for meat and he was
given broiled fish and honeycomb so yes
you'll live a better life on earth
health wise but as far as eternity has
no bearing on that correct well whenever
a person has light revealed to them the
Bible promises if we walk in the light
as he is in the light his blood cleanses
us from all sin so if a person learns
new things that are better for their
health you know if a person is convicted
I'm going to be healthier if I you know
do this or that they'll be blessed if
they follow that whatever it is and
that's not just talking about diet sin
is knowing to do good and not doing it
there are gonna be people in heaven that
had too many wives I won't go to heaven
if I start taking extra wives because I
know better so you know I don't want to
give you I don't want to get cornered
into an answer that says it doesn't
matter what you eat or drink is the
bible does say we can eat and drink to
God's glory you would also enjoy the
lesson that we just offered to two
callers previous on God's health plan
yes I will send it to you for free it's
called God's free health plan you know
think just to add to that little bit
pastor day the Bible is pretty clear
that our bodies are the temple of the
Holy Spirit
we live in different places around the
world and different cultures but I think
the principle that we find is we want to
take care of ourselves the best that we
can and utilizing the resources that are
available living even eating to the
glory of God that's that's absolutely
well if you call Renauld we appreciate
that the next call that we have is Bob
listening in Texas hi Bob well you have
about two minutes before the break hello
pastor Doug hello pastor Tom thank you
for taking my call thank you a quick
question
I read in John 16 that before Jesus
Christ ascended to heaven he totally
disciples it is history your advantage
that I am going away for if I do not go
away the helper
the comforter will not come talking
about the Holy Spirit my question is um
didn't imply that Holy Spirit was either
not there before that or had a different
role before this and going back into the
Old Testament times because I believe
the Holy Spirit was there because if you
read Genesis 1 itself it says the Spirit
of the Lord moved upon the face of the
waters but it just seems like there was
something different there was you know
yeah let me let me jump in and see if I
could answer part of this we're going to
run out of time the Holy Spirit
obviously was there in the Old Testament
as well because you know several people
are filled with the Spirit of the Lord
but when Jesus ascended he said look you
know I can be with you all through the
spirit in a special way clearly at
Pentecost when he poured out the Holy
Spirit and the baptism of the Spirit
there was a power there are varying
degrees of the way that God the Spirit
comes into us when Christ ascended to
heaven and his sacrifice was declared
accepted and successful it basically
paved the way for the Holy Spirit to
come in a new fullness on the church and
all people that hadn't happened prior ly
prior to that friends we're just gonna
take a break you can hear the music kind
of chasing us into a corner here but
we're not going away we'll be back with
more questions in just about a minute
and a half so stay tuned and call we
have a couple of lines open 804 6 3 7 2
9 7
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're a month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
so on from public contacts after we
study Daniel 2 she had mentioned that
the stone represents not the second
coming of Jesus but the first coming of
Jesus so what should I tell her or how
banter this question yeah I think I've
heard that before but clearly when it
talks about not just the iron the Roman
Empire is the iron in Daniel chapter 2
but the stone doesn't come until you've
got the iron mixed with clay that is the
division of the Roman empires you get
the ten toes that's symbolic of the ten
horns that you find in Revelation
chapter 12 chapter 13 chapter 17 and so
it has to happen after the it's not the
first coming of Christ when Rome was
ruling the world it's the second coming
the other reason we know it says all of
the other kingdoms are pulverized and
blown away there are no other kingdoms
competing when the stone strikes the
image and it fills the whole earth
well there are other kingdoms in the
world right now so it's Christ hasn't
come yet okay alright thanks so much hey
thank you appreciate that and we do have
a lesson we can send you it's called
bowing to Babel no no it's called the
Millennial man on Daniel chapter 2 it's
called the Millennial man and we'll send
you there and I'm gonna call these eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you're gonna ask for the study
guide called
millennial man talks about Daniel
chapter 2 an exfoliating from Florida
Scott welcome to the program
hey welcome hey how you doing today
doing good thanks
hey this a great show this one it's a
listening to it I had a quick question
at work a couple of people had questions
the measurements on the ark and the
times of Noah and basically what if they
were coming down to his they were trying
to discuss with me okay so if all the
people in those times decided to jump on
his ark there would not have been enough
room so what is the feelings on that
biblically speaking well I think you're
right that there probably wasn't enough
cubic footage or passengers space on the
ark if everybody had said they believed
but the question is was the world being
destroyed because everybody believed or
was the world being destroyed because
the thoughts of men's hearts were only
evil continually
and so the reason cottony if everyone
starts believing he didn't need to
destroy the world it's because most of
the world had turned from God so there
was going to be a way of salvation made
for those who would be willing to repent
and it was presumed that would be the
minority so yeah I agree
there's probably there wasn't room for a
hundred thousand people on the ark there
was certainly room for a lot more than
eight I wish our next year in the studio
with all these neutral
no questions because we're doing a lot
of nutrition proteins and things over
here at North Lake Church here the
little church and media burg would pass
her graham and the rest of us over here
good for you yeah well you know it's
amazing how much Christians are now
thinking more about their bodies they're
just realizing the Bible has a lot more
to say than they thought the reason God
gave all these health laws to the Jews
was not because it was all ceremony a
lot of it was just practical health to
help them live longer and thrive all
right hey thank you for your question
the next caller that we have is nee Haas
from Michigan I believe nails welcome to
the program
oh thank you so much pastor I am from
Canada oh okay hello yes yeah so cause I
have a question about Cain white so I
really got a lot of question from
unbelievers telling me like if God is
real and he created Adam and Eve and he
said that Adam and Eve out they had only
two sons so where it can get his wife
because he is who sent him away and I
also have a question about special
resurrection if you don't mind you can
explain it to me let's do them one at a
time okay yeah first let's talk about
Cain's wife and we get this question
probably once a month about people
reading through the Bible the first big
conundrum they come to says Cain took
his wife where she come from there's
only two boys that are mentioned well
you read on in Genesis chapter five and
it says Adam Eve had other sons and
daughters and you know they were they
were procreating and being the
productive and multiplying for probably
two hundred years at least and Cain took
one of his sisters there was nothing
wrong with marrying your sisters in the
early days of the world's history there
were no genetic problems and I like to
remind people that Abraham married his
half-sister Sarah he and Sarah had the
same father and Jacob married his first
cousin
Isaac married his first cousin it wasn't
and that odd back then the only reason
really back you know when God made
humanity there's no problem to marry
someone close to the family tree those
are the only people Cain grabbed one of
his sisters when he ran off
and started his own city and the verse
you referring to bastard I use Genesis
chapter 5 verse 4 talks about Adam lived
800 years any its sons and daughters yep
I think I said Genesis 5 that's correct
thank you yeah preciate and your second
question you said about the special
resurrection who will take part cuz in
Revelation chapter 1 verse 7 they said
like those who Pierce him they will see
him and the Bible say that only those
who will take part in the first
resurrection ad the Russia's so how will
they wake up and they are not among the
Russia well the reason it's called the
special resurrection is the ones who are
partaking in the condemnation the
judgment and the execution of Jesus that
were you know mocking him and doubting
who he was God is going to pull them out
of the graves for a special resurrection
once since he might say they're getting
raised twice and they're dying three
times so they can see the glory they
were mocking and saying he wasn't the
Son of God he and say well look you're
gonna see me come and he's gonna raise
them for that as a sign of special
judgment you can actually reading
Matthew chapter 26 verse 64 with Jesus
he's standing before the high priest and
finally the high priest says I adjure
thee by the Most High
are you the Christ Jesus then responds
to him and says it is as you say this is
verse 64 nevertheless I say to you
hereafter you will see the Son of man
sitting at the right hand of power and
coming in the clouds of heaven so it
seemed that those who played a leading
role in the crucifixion of Jesus they
are resurrected to see Jesus come and
it's because they asked the question are
you the Christ give us proof give us
evidence jesus said you will have
evidence you will see me coming again
very good thank you for your question
sure appreciate that and who do we have
next year next poll that we have is a
joy listening in Kansas City Joey
welcome to the program
well hello thank you I'm a first-time
caller I've been listening to you all
pre-recorded in Kansas City
oh well Korea show thank you I just have
a couple of quick questions because you
can talk a lot about diet
I thought there
was a place in Isaiah near 50 had talked
about the abomination when Jesus comes
back you can't be eating with it I was
hoping you could make it clear yeah is
that where he said the abomination and
the mouse pastor Ross yeah is that
Isaiah 66 or 65 I'm trying to remember
he's looking it up right now you just
type in the word malson it'll probably
come up there no I know I'd say pastor
Ross is looking it up for you yeah he's
looking up for you right now and yeah I
think it's uh it says with fire and with
a sword the Lord will come and plead
with all flesh in the slain of the Lord
will be many in that day yeah you're
talking about Isaiah 66 verse 17 correct
yeah those are justify themselves and
sanctify themselves in a garden eating
the abomination the abomination of the
mouse yeah putting swine and mouse in
the same category well I tell people I
did actually prosthetics or even if it's
in the Old Testament No thank you very
much a man my primary question was with
regard to the area in the book of I
believe revelation where it talks about
the ten commandments and the patience of
the saints and they also have the spirit
of prophecy that was the primary thing
yeah you'll find it mentions in
Revelation of course it says last thing
in the last chapter practically in
revelation 22 blessed are those that do
His commandments that they might have a
right to the Tree of Life in it or
through the gates of the city in
Revelation 12:17 it says the dragon is
Roth with a woman and goes to make war
with a remnant of her seed they keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus which later is
described in Revelation 19:10 it's the
spirit of prophecy
and then in Revelation 14 what does it
say blessed are those who keep his
Commandments right and have the faith of
g-eight of Jesus yeah so yeah Revelation
is pretty clear that God expects his
people not to obey the law to be saved
but because we do love him and we are
saved they will be an obedient people a
lot of talk these days about you know
just believe and you can continue
sinning like everyone else but the Bible
doesn't teach that God
to be victorious revelation says to him
that overcomes and the Lord wants us to
grow in sanctification good questions
that we do have a lesson that's talked
talks about this called or written in
stone that's right we'll be happy to
send it to anybody who has more
questions on this the number is 883 five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
study guide called written in stone the
next caller that we have is Mason
listening from looks like Charlotte
Mason welcome to the program they sent
you there from Charlotte North Carolina
Leighton Nathan alright thanks thank you
calling Nate Nathan from Charlotte North
Carolina my question is about revelation
13 specifically the seven heads and the
ten horns I'm curious about the seven
heads and the ten horns and I'm also
curious about the deadly wound and the
dates of the deadly wound and the
healing of the deadly wound alright well
I don't know how to tell you this but we
got like a three-minute budget per
question and I won't be able to answer
all of that in a three minutes let me
take a stab at it I'll start and then if
we run out of time please send for our
lesson on who is the Antichrist right
and it describes most of what you're
asking there you know you've real before
before you answer that we do have a DVD
called the bride the Beast in Babylon oh
yeah and it gets right into these
notices and I actually have a think I
might have that other piece of material
of a lesson good but I just wanted to
know just specifically what the seven
heads and the ten horns represent all
right well when you get to revelation 17
you see a woman sitting on a beast with
seven heads and the angel interprets he
says the seven heads are seven mountains
on which the woman sits well a Rome is
called the city of seven hills there are
also seven primary kingdoms that
persecuted God's people in the Old
Testament times and well actually even
through prophetic history and if you
look in that study guide it'll talk
about that and then you asked about the
time period and the deadly wound well
the time period when this beast power
begins to rain most Protestants now
friends I'm going to say something I
know it's gonna generate some questions
but it's not just me it's Luther Calvin
Spurgeon Wesley you name your favorite
Protestant theologian they all read
revelation 17 and they said it described
the church in Rome that they felt had
become unfaithful to the word and was
involved in idolatry and a lot of
compromise and so there was a time
period when the church in Rome had
strong political power it really began
when the Emperor Justinian gave the Pope
of Rome an army to enforce his decrees
and 538 ad if you go three and a half
prophetic years or 1260 days and if a
day equals a year that's 1260 years from
538 it comes to 1798 when the Catholic
Church lost its power over Europe
because Napoleon came into power and
they actually arrested the Pope and put
him in prison and I think he died in
captivity and Vallance France but that
deadly wound was healed and they came
back and became a political power again
like you know back in 1928 and that's
why the Pope just spoke to American
Congress and United Nations and there's
ambassadors that go to the Vatican
because they are a political power now
that's a lot to swallow and that's why I
knew we couldn't cover it all so please
do send for the lesson or look at the
DVD online just type in bride beast
Babylon I think we got one of our
YouTube channels there's got 750,000
views on that one YouTube so it's been
pretty popular who's next pastor alright
the next one that we have is Leeanne
listening in Florida and Leanne welcome
to the program hi get my passes you know
my question is my husband had on lunch
with some of our church members and
there was a couple there that
that had mentioned that sabot actually
starts from dawn on Saturday to dawn on
Sunday and he used verses like Matthew
Matthew 28:1 and John 20:19 to make his
point I was wondering if you could
explain those verses to me and to
explain why you know the sabot is not
from doe on Saturday - dawn Sunday
well--there's yeah okay good question
it's pretty clear from a number of
verses you can look in the Old Testament
and God said from even unto even you
will celebrate your Sabbath's and again
I think it's a Gospel of Mark it says
and at sundown when the Sabbath ended
and they wanted to get Jesus body off
the cross Friday afternoon before the
Sabbath you just there's so many
different places you could look at
people came to Jesus after the Sun went
down to have their sick healed because
they thought they weren't supposed to
have them healed on Sabbath of course
Christ never saw told them that but it's
just one more place where it shows they
recognize the Sabbath began and ended at
sundown days in the Bible did not begin
at sunrise
they began and they ended at sunset and
so we do have a study well for one thing
we get a website that's got all these
verses and many more called Sabbath and
truth calm anyone out there listening if
you want to see just it's it's the best
website out there that has information
on the Sabbath and the history of it and
just go to Sabbath truths calm and
you'll see tons of scriptures there
would you mind explaining Matthew 28:1
for me and John 20:19 yeah all right
let's go to Matthew 28 verse 1 and ain't
going here that's of course talking
about the resurrection now after the
Sabbath is the first day of the week
began to dawn where the Sabbath ended
sundown Saturday evening and it says as
the first day of the week began to dawn
first day would have been Sunday he's
talking about the sunrise it's not
saying the Sabbath ended at sundown it's
just saying Sabbath was past
and now first day the Sun was coming up
and the other one you wanted was John
20:19
okay John 20 verse 19 and it says in the
same day at even being the first day of
the week when the doors were shut and
the disciples were assembled for fear of
the Jews Jesus came well that says that
the Sun is going down Sunday afternoon
the first day is not over yet and was
telling us it's around Twilight that's
when Christ appeared to them it's the
same day of the resurrection mm-hmm okay
okay thank you all right
hey thank you very much appreciate your
call the next holy is Stephanie
listening from Columbia North Carolina
Stephanie welcome to the program hi good
evening pastors how are you doing
great how are you I'm doing good I have
a question regarding revelation 4 verses
7 and 8 I can't read it my Bible is in
French revelation 4 talks about the 24
elders and for being I was told that the
24 elders are representative of unfallen
world who are the four beings then well
the describable of course is a number of
symbols in Revelation the Bible
describes these four creatures around
the throne of God and it also mentions
them not only in Revelation but it's
Ezekiel as a chapter one talks about the
chair of them yes every wheels
yeah round the the there's four again
there that's sort of a picture there of
the universal leadership of God the
Bible talks about it we'll send His
angels to the four corners of the earth
and these creatures are full of eyes
it's describing the all-knowing ability
of God each of the faces of the
creatures says something about the
gospel you've got to think it's an eagle
a calf a man and a lion starts with the
lion starts with a line yeah I didn't
get him in the right line after I am
this is his cat go ahead and you got the
lion the Ox the man
in the Eagle yeah that's kind of the
representation of it some have seen in
that just added real quick I mean these
are living creatures that sort of form
God's throne you also ever described in
Ezekiel chapter 10 but some have seen in
this sort of a miniature of the plan
Redemption to some degree you got a line
which represents Christ position prior
to the incarnation you have the Ark's
which is a beast of burden Jesus came to
bear our sins to die in a place that ox
is a sacrificial animal as well then you
have one that has the face of a man and
people have seen in that Jesus our High
Priest ministering for us in heaven and
an eagle representing royalty or
kingship Jesus comes again as king of
kings and Lord of lords so there's some
parallels that people have seen in the
description of the four living creatures
I also saw that people made a pretty
good case for and it goes along
perfectly with what you're saying that
in the Gospel of Matthew he talks about
Jesus as the Lion of the tribe of Judah
Jesus is the king and in the Gospel of
John Jesus is the sacrifice and the
Gospel of Luke Luke was a physician
chose Jesus the humanity of Jesus and
mark is the fastest gospel and it's just
a quick flyover it's Jesus the eagle and
so you're even in the four Gospels you
can kind of see a picture of that but
yeah that is a deep and wide verse and
so the 24 elders I'm inclined to agree
and know there's a few different
theories I think they are
representatives of unfallen worlds and
you would see that also in the book of
Job yes and the book of Job they refer
to as the sons of God yeah and you
reading Psalms it talks about the Lord
reigning before his elders gloriously so
you read about this group of people the
elders these beings even in the Old
Testament very good hey thank you so
much appreciate your call and your
question and we'll see if we can get a
few more in before we would run out of
time we have tightly listening in
Oklahoma Tyler welcome to the program hi
I'm Tyler I'm from Oklahoma City and I'm
when questioned it is and six and Exodus
16 23 it talks about not baking or
heating on the Sabbath so I was
wondering does that mean that I
can't use my oven or my microwave on the
Sabbath well I don't think there'd be a
problem with using a microwave the whole
idea of not cooking your food on Sabbath
was that it was often very time
consuming when you bake bread they used
to have to build a big fire and then
they'd get a bed of coals and then the
bread would be needed and the bread
would rise and they put it in there and
they bake it and it's a big process it
involved a lot of work and when you were
boiling or sieving something you have to
again heat up the fire put the water on
it boil it and cook things for a while
these were labor-intensive you know the
whole principle of the Sabbath you get
everything done you can do in advance so
if you can get your food ready in
advance and just nuke it with a
microwave I don't see a problem with
that my wife is she's so thankful she's
got this time bake oven she just presses
one button we go to church we come home
and it goes ding and it's ready so it's
it's not that there's a sin in using a
convenience to heat up your food the
ideas anything you can do in advance and
do it and avoid labor-intensive things
and so I you know I fill my car with gas
Friday I get my suit and everything set
out I know what I'm wearing the next day
so I'm not rushing around wondering oh
do I have anything to wear and I just
want it to be a holy day so when I wake
up Sabbath morning you know everything
is ready you're prepared and you can
really rest and so yeah if you can
should make every effort I think to cook
your food in advance if you can some
things you know salad you might need to
toss that keep it fresh that makes sense
Tyler yeah thank you very much I thinks
you sound like a very bright young man
appreciate your call all right I think
we have time for hopefully one more we
got woody listening from Georgia what do
we have just a few minutes okay good
evening pastors how are y'all great
thank you for calling with your question
yes just a quick question it's about the
Lord's Prayer and as couple of us we're
talking to work the other day in the
middle of it it says lead us not into
temptation well I don't believe the Lord
would ever lead us into temptation and I
wanted to know if you could clarify that
for me you know it's
funny you would ask that Pastor Ross and
I just looked smiled nodded each other
because today in a devotional that we
did with the man I talked about the
Lord's Prayer and I talked about that
very question that verse yeah
it's often misunderstood it sounds like
we're begging God not to tempt us but
the Bible says God is not tempted with
evil neither can he does he tempt any
men alright it's basically saying Lord
lead us away from our natural
inclination to temptation so you know
we're all prone to sin I think job said
as the sparks fly upward so man is prone
to do evil and we're just saying Lord
lead us away from our inclination
towards sin and temptation we need to
ask God to lead us in the right
direction and that should be part of our
prayer we're not begging him not to
tempt us you know just one additional
foot on that Jesus said in Matthew 26
verse 41 watch and pray lest you intend
to temptation so in order for us to not
go into temptation we need to watch and
pray so in essence the Lord's praise
Lord remind me to watch and pray that
way we'll be led away from temptation
and the spirit you know I found when I
pray and say Lord keep me from
temptation God gives me the spirit so
that if I start drinking and my thinking
the Holy Spirit will say ah you're going
the wrong way and he guides you and say
oh thank you Lord absolutely they
listening friends it would not be doing
anybody justice if we took just a
fraction of your phone call right now if
we did not get to your call this week
God willing we're going to be back next
week and we encourage you to call in
with your questions you can also even
send your questions to us at amazing
facts we do answer a lot of Bible
questions via the internet and you can
go to our website amazing facts of dot
o-r-g and find out more about that there
then and while you're at the website
amazing facts not o RG you're gonna see
that we stream live programs each week
we get a stream of Bible study Tuesday
there's a lot of archived sermons
questions books that are free we want
you to grow in your faith so much of
what we do could not be done without
your help friends if you'd like to keep
us on the air
you can donate there at the website
just click and we'd love to hear from
you god bless
till we talk again together
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before tune in next time for
more Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible questions
[Music]
hello friends we all know a marathon is
one of the longest and hardest races a
person can run but did you hear about
the ultra marathon that used to have in
Australia it was 544 miles from
Melbourne to Sydney it attracted as many
as a hundred and fifty world-class
athletes but then something happened
that no one would ever forget in 1983 a
61 year old potato farmer named cliff
young decided to enter the race people
were very amused because he had on
rubber galoshes over his boots and when
the race began and all the runners took
off sure enough old cliff was left
behind shuffling along very slowly but
he was shuffling very persistently
normally during this seven-day race the
runners would go about 18 hours running
and then they'd sleep for six hours but
nobody ever told cliff that when the
other runners stopped to rest during the
night cliff just kept on running some
people were afraid old cliff was gonna
have a heart attack and they were asking
the race organizers to show mercy and
stop the crazy old man but he would have
none of it each day he was gaining on
the pack because when they were sleeping
he was plodding along
during the last night of the race cliff
passed all of these world-class athletes
not only was cliff able to run that 544
mile race without dying
he won beating all the other racers by
nine hours breaking the record and
becoming a national hero in the process
what's really amazing is when they told
him that he had won the $10,000 prize he
looked confused and said he didn't know
there was a prize and he decided to
share it with the other runners when
asked how he was able to run all night
long cliff responded that he grew up on
a farm where they had about 2,000 head
of cattle and because they couldn't
afford horses used to have to round them
up on foot sometimes running two and
three days non-stop so throughout the
race he just imagined he was chasing
after the cows and trying to help run a
storm old cliffs secret was to keep on
running while others were sleeping you
know the Bible tells us that the race is
not necessarily to the Swift something
like Aesop's parable of the tortoise in
the hare the tortoise just kept on
plodding along
that's why Jesus tells us in Matthew
24:13 he that endures unto the end the
same will be saved now you might slip
and fall during the race you might even
get off to a bad start but in the
Christian race that we run the main
thing is you want to finish we'll keep
on running friends and don't give up
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF act 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 RG